uploading and downloading is all fine
and good but sometimes you need to do
more maintenance on the data in your
buckets today on cloud storage bytes
we're going to dig into object
management so stick around no matter how
you get your data into Google Cloud
storage once it's there it's manageable
meaning easy to manage just how easy
easy as 1-2-3 let's talk about lists you
see what I did there
anytime you want to do something with
the objects in your bucket it helps to
know what's there starting with a list
will get you the inventory you need of
all of those 11720 three data objects
you've got but if you've somehow got
that memorized feel free to skip ahead
as we talked about when getting data in
there are two main options for
interacting with your cloud storage
command line GS util and the cloud
console spoiler alert this is going to
be true for awhile so listing the
contents of a bucket with GS util you'll
get a nice structured response making it
easy to see what you've got and where
and of course the cloud console offers a
convenient visual interface with
dropdowns and buttons for looking at all
of your files and directories so now
that we know what's in your bucket
let's talk changes rename an object with
a few specific steps copy the object
making another instance of it either in
the current bucket or in any other
bucket move the object into a new bucket
and for a more permanent change you can
always delete an object removing it from
the bucket and effectively from your
cloud storage the command line utility
was designed to be as easy to remember
and as easy to navigate as the cloud
console so these commands might even
look familiar to you if you're used to
working in the command terminal no
matter how you work with it Google Cloud
Storage is going to give you the
flexibility you need to create the
perfect solution for your needs now
there's plenty more that you can do with
your data and Google Cloud Storage but
that's for another episode subscribe
give us a like and let us know what
features of cloud storage you want to
learn more about thanks for joining us
for this quick byte of Google Cloud
storage see you next time
[Music]